hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the Tim Dylan
show it is the final episode without
video I know that a lot of the YouTube
community and what a disgusting coupling
of words huh YouTube community is very
upset that there's no video video is
coming speaking of the YouTube community
I was flying back from New York to LA
and I was boarding the plane and they
announced that we didn't have any Wi-Fi
so I was just I was trying to I was
downloading stuff on Netflix to watch
and I was going through you know it's
firing off my last tweets unless the
plane goes down and I saw this James
Charles is over parties trending and
James Charles is apparently a beauty
he's a beauty guru who's worth like
twelve million dollars and he gives
makeup tutorials on YouTube that's a big
market
I don't know when everyone went so
[ __ ] insane with the makeup where
it's now you know making people tens of
millions of dollars I like when people
wear makeup it's nice when people look
good I'm a capitalist Pig I don't mind
walking to a glossy department store and
having a bunch of people spray cologne
in my face I like that I like it cuz you
get in their face getting that little
woman's face and go can I eat it can I
taste it go spray it on my back and then
they always kind of flinch and then it's
fun I don't mind any of that I just
don't know when
Beauty consultations became like a
billion-dollar industry
these people are making so much [ __ ]
money and I don't even know James Sean I
guess he's a gay dude but when you look
at him he pries I don't even know
between the plastic surgery and the
makeup now everybody looks like a
character from babes in toyland so I
don't even know what people are anymore
like I don't even know what people
nobody has their original face everybody
is made up they look like they're a
character from you know march of the
wooden soldiers I have no idea anymore
is this person trans are they non-binary
or they caged I don't even know
especially on YouTube you barely know
anymore but this guy they tried to
cancel him once and I don't know why
they said he was a sexual predator which
I don't think he was backed up by
anything it might have been I mean
contra points to the video today that
youtuber that I like and a and she was
like that basically this other makeup
vlogger whatever you call him accused
this guy James cha and there's a reason
I'm talking about all this by the way
and again it would be easy to ignore all
of this [ __ ] but these people are making
doodles of [ __ ] money I mean they're
making a lot of money you can't ignore
all of it like you can't just ignore
everything cuz it is culture and
something's going on you look around the
world you like you something is going on
when the videos of people opening a
present are getting a hundred million
views and and people people's lives are
so empty that they want to watch
somebody else take something out of a
box
there's a problem here it's a big
problem you can't ignore it you can't
just say well it's just the kids the
kids are wacky I think it's something
else I think there's something deeply
there's a psychosis we're entering I
have and I have an interest in exploring
why and how we're entering it I don't
think it's just the same thing as like
people not getting the Beatles okay when
the biggest YouTube videos are our
children like watching people crumble
chalk in their hand
I think this disobey be an issue
underlying issue here that we should
explore so for those of you who are gone
or do Buzzard or foe shut up go make a
top 10 list of movies for the decade you
idiot who asked any of you to do that by
the way who came to you and said hey
bill can you rank your top 10 movies of
the decade and put it on Facebook so
that I can read them aloud to my family
I mean what kind of psycho by the way
you ranked at top 10 movies in a decade
I immediately know you're mentally ill I
immediately know you should go in a cage
and be locked away forever because you
put out your top 10 films of the decade
ears for my money these are the top 10
films and shut up stop ranking making
lists the top 10 films of the decade who
cares what you have to say your 386
Facebook friends what are you looking
for a fight you looking for somebody to
go I don't thank God
cut gems would should make it well what
are you looking for you that hungry for
interaction that you're thrown at you
would he expect somebody's gonna go this
was a brilliant list Tom this was very
smart I forgot about some of the movies
from the beginning of the decade that
you remembered you're sharp I always
said that to my wife I said Tom sharp
can't wait for his year-end list but so
James Charles they tried to cancel them
once Conger points was basically like
listen the dude's not a sexual predator
if she tried to get somebody accused
would try to convince straight guys
they're gay every gay guy myself
included want to hook up with straight
guys that's just a reality so that's not
the same thing as being sexual predator
okay I mean I guess if you if you tie
them to a thing or whatever that's not
good but it's not the same thing
but now they they try to cancel did you
and I have no I don't know who the dude
is I'm not a fan of whatever he does but
now they're canceling him because he's
he supposedly somebody found the video
of him singing the n-word on New Year's
Eve that's in a song like they they on
his Instagram story supposedly he sang
along with a rap song and there was an
n-word in it and they're canceling for
that by the way is there anything less
like is there anything to me and is
there like is there anything that flies
in the face of whatever the spirit of
rap and hip-hop is supposed to be then a
bunch of rats online like a bunch of
rats and tattletales online trying to
get like when that when that rapper I
forget who did it was it a sound that
problem
who was the rapper that brought the
chick up on stage we're in a car right
now as a bank can look it up Busey
Kendrick Lamar who's great rapper but he
brings a chick about stage she sings the
n-word along with a song and he like he
used it as a teachable moment it's like
dude what kind of rap is this what kind
of tattletale [ __ ] rat [ __ ] is this
and I don't think white people should
use the n-word but like are you really
scouring people's Instagram stories to
catch them singing along with it and you
people are go you're Tim you're a
[ __ ] fat white guy from the suburbs
are you gonna tell us what the spirit of
rap is yes we bought all the albums
yes I'm exactly to tell you what the
spirit of rapid spirit of rap this me
and my friends driving around my friend
Mike Morris his mother's Saturn and
listing the g-unit and going through the
Tootsie unit and go into private school
so that's what it is because we
respected the code of the streets we
respected loyalty you know we there was
an idea of people that came from shitty
environments that were tough and we
respected them the toxic masculinity it
damn right it was but we respected it it
wasn't some kunti rat behavior will you
go online and you find this [ __ ] guy
you sing along to the n-word which again
I you know I'm not for I'm not
say the n-word but it seems like a low
threshold to cancel someone now in a
culture that we're in seems pretty low
of a threshold to throw somebody out you
can accidentally sing along with the
n-word it's just what happens uh uh you
know rap was rap you know it's supposed
to be like cool you know because it's
Yanis pop has made a great point on the
last podcast he's like when you're
sitting in a [ __ ] Applebee's and
journey comes on and a bunch of white
people start swaying you want to kill
yourself so then you go find cool things
like rap music that talks about an
experience that you didn't grow up with
because you grew up in a [ __ ] white who
cares Ville and rap this you know and
now everybody I get it everyone that's a
rapper now went abroad nice was cool
that I did we went to Catholic school
where the teachers used to make out with
the kids but these rappers you know half
of them went to like good schools in it
so digital marketing or whatever and you
know does your cat's a partner at
Goldman Sachs but the I get that it's
not what it was but still even for what
it is to just be a straight-up rat isn't
that supposed to help you Takashi
whatever his name is
he goes any rats out everybody it's like
that's supposed to be not cool that's
not supposed to be the move
I used to rat out everybody and I have
nothing to say about James Charles
either way whatever the guy's made
twelve million dollars painting his face
good for him he's made 12 sticks
painting his face
Jeffrey Star all these people have made
than 18 19 million YouTube subscribers I
had no idea how big of a deal
beauty and glamour was because I go out
in the real world and and and everybody
looks like [ __ ] so who is watching these
things and internalizing them and taking
them seriously I mean III guess it's you
know the argument doesn't hold up cuz
you know fitness people a lot of people
are watching that but you know the
countries two-thirds of the people in
the country can't lift their leg
so I understand that it doesn't always
trickle down to the streets i sat next
to a British guy on the plane the other
day and there's a and there's and
speaking of cancelling people I want to
cancel this type of disc let's be a lot
of British people are disgusting I'm
gonna come out and say that right now
and you know a lot of people are gonna
be angry at me a lot of people from the
UK and I specifically mean Britain are
disgusting there's not a lot of
attractive British women there's just
not it's just it's what it is I'm not
trying to get anyone upset it the teeth
are all [ __ ] up they they're not hot
people okay and there's this brand of
British hipster that people do think is
hot with like the man bun and they've
got like mangy gnarled hair and they're
dressing a hipster and like a black and
white striped shirt with leather boots
and you know their their father is you
know some Lord that sacrifices children
and they're there hanging out like
Battersea or some fun hipstery place in
Britain and I just they're just
disgusting people they're eating fish
pudding they're they're disgusting I'm
here to tell you the truth it's that
type of British in stir they always have
a man bun they have a man bun their Idol
is like Russell Brand they want to be
like the worldly guy that even though
he's white he's into Transcendental
Meditation and he understands what a bad
boy Whitey's been so to me it's a real
it's a real problem and I want to cancel
these people I want them gone and I'm
not saying a genocide I just don't to
sit next to them anymore I don't want to
sit next to them anymore on planes I'm a
little sick of it I'm a little sick of
their emaciated girlfriend who looks
like she needs to eat and she can't eat
because that all the food in the country
is absolutely repulsive
unless it's curry unless it's Indian
food and she's dating this [ __ ]
pretty
and just disgusting waif with his man
bond in his hair that he hasn't washed
in a week whose pride whose profile
pictures probably Greta Thun Berg cuz
he's a pedophile but he's just he's just
using climate change I just I just have
had enough with them I've had enough
with them looking like [ __ ] and acting
like they invented the world when you
look like [ __ ] total [ __ ] take a shower
you dirtbag it's the type of guy that
brings out an acoustic guitar at the
party nobody asked him to and everybody
wants to kill themself that's what it is
the type of guy who start strumming an
acoustic guitar and everybody goes who
the [ __ ] is this oh it's this British
guy this this exotic British guy who
just looks like a regular American piece
of [ __ ] but he's got an accent and he
thinks he's charming cuz he speaks
differently get in the shower and get an
outfit stop dressing like a Harlequin
clown like a circus person you and your
dead-eyed girlfriend on the [ __ ]
American Airlines flight in the exit
route which I [ __ ] hate that row now
I hate the eggs around every time I sit
in the eggs are all next to total pieces
of [ __ ] who think they should be in
business class because they could spring
an extra 90 for the exit row you're
still a pig do you understand me you're
not in another section of the plane
you're in the exit row you're nothing
you're not in business guy they think
it's like business class jr. being in
the [ __ ] exit route no it just means
a [ __ ] comes up to you and goes in it
in the event of a thing will you help
and you go yes and and you never get to
help because in the event of a thing we
all die I'm just a little sick of the
exit row attitude people that had the
extra hundred dollars the extra $79 to
spring from the exit row now think that
they're like [ __ ] the Rothschilds
they're gonna lord their power and
prestige over every
[ __ ] the exit row I'm done with the exit
row Christmas was uh you know I'm just
covering a lot of different things today
that have been bothering me you know and
then we'll settle into something
somatically at some point I guess or we
won't or we won't you'll deal with that
if we don't these are just things I've
getting off my chest in 2020 things that
we got to change as a culture and the
tolerance of the British hipsters we've
got our own shitty hipsters we've got
our own over privileged white guilty
white you know dilettante people who
pretend to be in the arts but they're
not we don't need to import them from
London get them out of here
give me the Asians my parents again my
boomer parents their generosity again
astounding for Christmas we gifted me a
leather bag and filled it with dayquil
and Ricola mints because I travel that's
when you know I got them this year zero
nada last year I got him dinner at Le
Bernardin which is a very nice
restaurant and they gave me a cheque
which was less than what I spent on
there gives certificates so I've decided
they will never get a present again for
the rest of their lives
there will be no presents for them I
love them but there will be no presents
for them and they can stop getting me
prizes whatever they want they can stop
read gifting me things and feeling they
would take well or they can if they like
whatever they want to do I think that
they leaned into the description of them
that I put out there because that's
literally what they did they found a
leather bag that they were no longer
using and they filled it with things
that I could use when I travel like
antibacterial hand wipes we wish you a
Merry Christmas they gave me what a Red
Cross shelter would give out to people
that was my Christmas present my
Christmas present is what a shelter
would give to somebody walking in who
was at the lowest point in their life
Merry Christmas
but we had fun with a nice time this
year it was at my stepmothers sister's
house we were
in and out two and a half hours in and
out boom boom boom by the way the length
of a family party is three hours that is
it you are in you are out our dinner our
dessert our in-between or maybe an hour
before dinner
bing-bam-boom her sister's a great cook
her sister-in-law she made shrimp scampi
and calamari calamari and eggplant all
that great [ __ ] in and out quick Fuqua
and i don't know any these people it's
so nice I don't know I barely know them
because they're all her relatives which
is so great
I love going in a room with essentially
strangers because everyone's polite and
nobody has anything to really discuss so
you make small talk and they say things
like oh I saw you in rogue and that's
nice comedy that's fun huh you know
there's always like an older guy who's a
kid the PCT how you handling the PC
thing and I'm always tempted to kind of
flip it on him on my care you can barely
talk about eating a guy's [ __ ]
anymore it's like people get upset with
you I don't do that cuz it's Christmas
but that is a fun way to flip it on
something he's like you hold this PC now
you comedians you can't really say none
I'm like hey you can't talk about
sucking off a dude people get really
upset it's like dude chill with the PC
culture what just his head like he's
mind melt his brain be like wait a
minute war oh but it's nice it's nice
now by the way let me read you the text
it was sent to me from my cousin who
went to my other family my cousin who
went to my other family he sent me this
text because apparently that melted down
so swiftly this is what I love it
my family and I talked about it before
it's an Irish family so we're on we're
in the final stage of it Irish families
are very good when the kids are young
and people still have hope and then
people you know their alcoholism hasn't
totally destroyed their lives and
they're not thrice divorced and they're
not living back with their mother and
everything hasn't fallen on his face yet
and there's the idea that the kids are
gonna take the family to the next level
they're gonna have better lives in their
parents
my family that is not the case nobody's
got married a few of us are even in
serious relationships I'm the gay clown
is the most successful bad news now the
younger kids are going to Villanova and
stuff then they might do better than me
hopefully they do but as far as with the
current crop of kids it's nobody's
filled with hope you know it's real sad
and and my father six brothers and
sisters five because one of them died
years and years ago melanoma I guess
they all hate each other now because
every family party they have just
descended to screaming and and gasps
just screaming a cast so I'm gonna read
you it was funny I mean again folks you
got enjoy it you got a drink I don't go
anymore because I just want to be with
strangers now I don't want to go anymore
because it's not it's fun for a few
times - screaming the cast then you say
to yourself you know what I gotta be
honest I'm getting bored with how much
you all hate each other because it's
boring it used to be kind of fun when it
would go off the rails but now it's just
gone off the rails so many [ __ ] times
you can't even find the value in it
you're just like of this again it's
boring we all hate each other
let's let's call it a day all these
families that keep getting together and
fighting there's no value in that it's
just over just let it be
you're not doing anything by getting
together and hating each other I'm gonna
hate show morning and shame room is damn
it just let it go so I'll find this tax
it was so fun it's really interesting
when you can you can you can call
something happening and then it actually
happens exactly the way you know we'll
talk about it I've seen a little bit
because everybody knew exactly what that
was and other news is finally catching
up and oh yeah they're intelligent ass
apparently apparently they are
intelligent assets and this might have
to do with Israel and say yeah everyone
knew that everyone's known that everyone
with Wi-Fi has know
that for months some of them years and
you [ __ ] have just caught up so this is
what my cousin texted me this was great
first of all let me read you the text
that my aunt sends to the family before
everybody gets there okay
I like this it's fun to me and a lot of
people are like oh these are private
communication off swimming okay about
that go scratch I got lawyers on
retainer to handle you [ __ ] Irish
lugs now my family's a bunch of Jews I
keep my mouth shot but what are you
gonna do you potato farmers what are you
gonna do I'll see in court I'll see you
in court baby who you gonna bring in
your bartender friend to represent you
Maliki so folks were having fun it's
just fun you know I sometimes have to
see these people it's very awkward case
you have to be in the same room with
these people and I forget out public
this all this you know hundreds of
thousands of people listen what are you
gonna do it's entertaining this is
entertaining because people I know are
mentally ill they're mentally ill so if
I can't capitalize off their sickness
and I don't mean mentally ill like
Instagram mentally ill where you're all
I'm dead because no one was here my shut
up mental illness by the way has become
a brand in this country
I'm anxiety man 19 to a 1992 it's like
it has become a [ __ ] brand and
there's a lot of comedians names not
mention that have enabled that and have
leaned into that and has become their
brand and and fine but what they've done
is they've enabled a group of people to
to basically pretend to be sick to have
an identity uh my mother's truly
mentally ill she's a schizophrenic she's
in a mental institution she's really
mentally ill like she thinks she said to
me once you know Elvis might be my
father
that's real mental illness okay she's
not powdi because sometimes she's
that's not real mental that most people
are depressed because their lives are
shitty and they're idiots
that's why you're depressed cuz you're
bad every decision you make is wrong
you've been coddled and told that you
were special and that you should go out
and be and follow your dreams you don't
even have dreams you wouldn't know what
they were you should fall in line find a
way find a job find a local pizzeria and
eat there that's what you should do you
should not be out trying to [ __ ]
[ __ ] Gary Vee notwithstanding you
should not be out trying to take over
the world and then you're all kinds of
depressed when you find out that you
didn't accomplish the thing you weren't
suited to do to begin with there's a
reason I'm not trying to win the Tour de
France okay cuz I'm not a [ __ ]
should I be depressed every day that I
can't get my fat ass on a bike and go
ride around loose no I should understand
that that's not what I'm on the planet
to do that's why half of you were
depressed cuz nobody tells you you're
living wrong I know comics whose
grandparents were in the sea I ain't
skullenbones there they trying to do
comedy I'm like will you get out of here
and go poison someone in the Moroccan
Embassy in [ __ ] models what's wrong with
you are you a [ __ ] are you stupid
if this is our country and the ruling
class wants to take improv is that what
john d rockefeller would be doing today
BB a in a sketch group putting out
YouTube videos I mean people have a
nature they have a nature they they you
you but if you're born rich you be rich
there's nothing to be gained from
pretending to [ __ ] be an artist
I'm not saying rich people can't be
artists by the way Mulaney is brilliant
there's a lot of brilliant guys that
crawls brilliant you know
and I and I and I say that because I
believe that and also because I see his
family but because they're not [ __ ]
around but the point is the the you know
but the point is this some rich people
got a lot I'm middle-class Mozart a very
few poor people have the luxury of
making people laugh for living I get
that most of us are you know I love
made the argument that you you know
we're like from the gooder it's just not
the case
but you meet some of these uber wealthy
people and there's nothing sadder than
seeing a rich person fail at being a
clown it's crazy and some of them are
pretty good at it it's still
disappointing it's still sad it's even
worse when they can kind of do it you're
almost like god damn it let me find this
because this is so much fun this is the
detects of my aunt sent which basically
means basically she's like I just don't
want anybody I just don't want anybody
uh to come that's basically the text
that was sent out where she goes I'm
just really not into having anybody come
that's all and but you shouldn't
explicitly say that but I'll tell you
this if you got this text you would say
to yourself oh [ __ ] I should not I
should turn around it's the [ __ ] the
craziest thing I've ever heard
and this was being sent around the
family because people just really
laughing at it because again this is
great this is one of my favorite acts
ever god this was a group text sent to
my family okay here we go
Merry Christmas the house is being
Decorah by the way the way this text
turns is one of my favorite things ever
again cuz I watch it now like a TV show
I have no investment in it so I watch it
like you know Ozark the house the
decorator the table is being set as a
reminder this is a in caps now group
effort I do not expect anyone to do
everything including myself but I do
expect in caps again everyone to do
something you're going to a party think
about this think about getting these
texts on your way to a party think about
getting this text on the way to a party
here we go back to the tack couple of
helpful hints during the day if people
could keep an eye out for empty plates
use napkins and empty cans
as cops and dispose of them along with
disposing of their owner would be a big
help after dinner and people could join
in with clearing the table and bring
there already you should already you
don't go already if you're saying you do
not go after dinner people could join in
with clearing the table and bring their
own and or their kids digit to the
kitchen it would be helpful we are using
the good Christmas China it needs to be
rinsed I will load it into the
dishwasher the soup bowls just need to
be rinsed and set aside on the kitchen
table I will do them later all of the
good flatware will be put in a large pot
with hot soapy water those two will be
done later on the 9 cup and the 6 cup
pots will be used for coffee many hands
will make light work if we all pitch in
we can all have a fun and relaxing
holiday yeah that's what this sounds
like a fun and relaxing holiday doesn't
that what this sounds like Timmy's
spending holidays with Christina's
family this year so please if you plan
on drinking wine plan accordingly that's
my dad he's not he's not bringing a wine
this year so she's basically like if you
want to drink wine you bring your own
you're not dipping into my stash Pig
she says you plan on drinking wine plan
accordingly and Tim if I did not thank
you properly on Thanksgiving I apologize
thank you view generosity he gets the
wine free whatever I I hope you
Christina never another fantastic and
very Merry Christmas all the depending
on our mom's blood pressure doing that
and maybe taking it several times a day
I tell you this in case you want to
mention it to your kids so that they
don't get nervous we were trying to
titrate her meds let by the way there
are no kids the kids are adults you
could just say it in the room there's no
little babies there's no children they
need to be told about nannies blood
pressure they're adults micawber
checking down his blood pressure we're
trying to last week the doctor
introduced a new med into the mix of
president I know that I state that here
as if it is a possibility with low blood
pressure
well out with low blood pressure so that
was the whole tax it was sent to the
family
okay that was sent to the family
everybody pitch in everybody help we
don't want any dirty dishes or plates we
got to keep an eye on man's blood
pressure now here's a text I get two
hours into Christmas two hours into
Christmas this is the text I get okay
this is [ __ ] wild just keep the first
text as that's the table setting for the
second one because everybody's concerned
about you know the house looking nice
and you know everything being everything
has a proper place and we just want to
make sure that everybody is you know
everybody is okay all right so here's
the text that I get Christmas Eve 7:38
aunt Kay my mom aunt Carol blowout fight
Kathleen and garage crying Carol taking
walk around the block
Tomasz out there yelling at Kathleen
she's acting ridiculous Jesus Christ
won't even make it to dessert I'm like
what are they fighting about he wrote
dishes it's so crazy to me you fight
about like after that whole long tax is
just a blowout fight and it'll start
with the dishes and it'll go into like
something crazy so this is why I just
don't I just separate from it and I just
from afar I kind of like check in on it
every now and then somebody sent me
attacks because it's just it's just gone
off the red and it used to go off the
rails around 3:00 oh yeah I'm but it'd
be fun until then but now it just goes
off the rails an hour in there's not
even fun it's just it's pointless it's
but I feel bad I feel bad I don't really
have that like my younger cousins I
don't see that much I don't I don't have
any a huge relationship with them which
is kind of sad but if they get on
tik-tok and get a following we could
maybe start we could do a collab I
appreciate that but it's just so funny
to see like so many messages from people
this year that were like you know what
I've just really started to look at like
my family and friends in another light
and I've said to myself I just don't
need toxic people you don't
you either reality is there's always
some angle where people like well you
know what you're doing it for your
mother you're doing it for you and you
know after a while that's no longer true
because you're like we're just making
everyone's life worse by subjecting
everybody to this it's okay move on you
have one life
don't waste it with people that for
whatever read just cuz you were born
with people or you were friends with
them for a stretch of time does it mean
you're indebted to them and you have to
[ __ ] spend every meaningful moment of
your life with them until everybody goes
insane and kills each other it's just
not what has to happen and I think my
family think this is probably the
breaking point unfortunately for my
grandmother who I love and adore but I
think it's the breaking point where
people are genuinely like we're kind of
done now I think people are like we're
just
we've just had enough and I mean you
know that's the new thing everybody says
brain damage yeah we're say there was a
girl heckling me at Fort Worth screaming
like a lunatic and then when she was
confronted her boyfriend at the table
goes oh I'm sorry she has brain damage
so this is the new way that people don't
have to account for their behavior he's
saying it to have brain that I have a
neurological issue of brain damage that
brain damage
sorry sorry my girlfriend uh started
screaming in the top of her lungs
calling the comedian accont it's brain
damage she has a brain disorder I was
like I think her brains working fine
she's just a [ __ ] lunatic she's a
problem speaking of people who have
brain disorders I want to thank Joe
DeRosa for calming a Republican in the
interrobang I love job kidding Joe's a
great comedian and a friend that I do
enjoy him he's one of those guys at
convenience a is really smart which is
never a good sign you know and all these
comedians look that guy's smart it's
like a buddy when clowns elect you is
there a there you know as the guy that's
intelligent and by the way I'm
people say that about me and I was
cringe I'm Joe DeRosa
it was kind of funny they asked him
who's gonna be big in 2020 I got Tim
Dylan's a gay Republican he's gonna he's
gonna make it you know Chappell made it
he said it was all like you know the
whole thing happened where it was
everyone a straight white man and the
Dave Chappelle came out and everyone's
like nubs just man and that's him til
make it all men again including gay men
it's like it's just old straight man and
now it'll be old man so it's kind of
funny but then a couple of people were
like oh dude or APOBEC I'm like listen I
don't it truly I don't care what anyone
says about me at all buy the ticket buy
the shirt I really don't care anymore
what you could call yourself will you
call me will you call anybody call
anybody whatever you want you [ __ ]
think they give a [ __ ] does it matter
I just had a great lunch at Manhattan
Beach with Steven paddock the great
friend there's a close friend of mine
he's someone I've grown to respect in
the last few months he's got he's a
[ __ ] Patriot I really don't care what
anyone says these definitions don't mean
anything the mainstream media's finally
caught up with the fact that you're
slaying Maxwell and Jeffrey Epstein were
working for Anna for an intelligence
service thanks guys thanks for your due
diligence over there the mainstream
media I'm glad you stopped covering Liz
OHS thigh for five minutes and you were
able to kind of key in on what's
probably the biggest political scandal
of our time good job this is obvious to
everyone I said before anybody with a
Wi-Fi connection anybody paying the
least amount of attention to anything
knew this they knew it and they knew it
with the Franklin scandal and with the
King chorus boys home and Ireland these
[ __ ] you know when Lord Mountbatten
Mount Mont Ponton whatever his name is
these demonic you know people in the
royal family and whatever we're doing
horrible things to kids and then being
recorded and then having that
information being used against him in
blackmail going on for a very very long
time you know and I bet you slain
Maxwell right now man they'd really love
to get rid of her they
can't really kill her right now cuz it
would be like it would be too much but
man they really they didn't expect like
the fact that she's still around he's
not really working out well for anybody
the fact that she's still around in the
FBI might you know starting to be
interested in her and they're starting
to investigate people like her and some
of these other acquaintances maybe guys
that Glenn do Ben the billionaire hedge
fund manager in New York maybe not I
don't know that they're investigating
him I'm not saying they are but he
allegedly you know along would you say
max where were like threatening
fifteen-year-old girls from Sweden that
they had you know brought to the country
and everything because they didn't want
to have sex supposedly this guy very
creepy dude that had a relationship with
I've seen in New York I don't really
know what acquaintances or
co-conspirators they're looking into but
you know that was one article that I
read today yeah it's like the Boston
Marathon bombing they didn't want the
little one to live like nobody wanted
the little guy to live and he did like
they were shooting into that boat to get
rid of both of them she the idea that
just Lane is still walking around
doesn't help anybody at least she's out
of the public eye she disappeared in
2016 I think she resurfaced and an event
in Switzerland or Sweden and it was like
a you know whatever high-end event
cocktail party garden party wherever the
hell she was and that was the last time
she'd been seen publicly and that of
course is that photo of her you know and
in and out with that dumb book that said
the secret lives of intelligence
operatives that's the [ __ ] book
that's the book she's holding in the
thing she the mainstream media just
finally figured out that maybe they had
something to do with intelligence the
woman who was holding a book that said
the secret lives were tough as if to say
[ __ ] you look at me they finally figured
out its the it's it's her version of OJ
Simpson's book if I did it that was that
photo of jizz Lane Maxwell holding the
intelligence book
that's like the media finally getting
around if they had gone to sleep on oj
and then he wrote a booklet if i did it
they were still like we don't understand
all these conspiracies with oj i wonder
why people are so hell-bent on thing he
had something to do with it and then
eventually being like well we've looked
at the facts and perhaps perhaps or in
full james simpson did have some he does
bear some responsibility it's funny they
want her out they want her dead I mean
they want her dead she's got a lot of
information on a lot of powerful people
she you know if you read the story like
a story which it is you know she is
Epstein's quote-unquote what it with
whether you want to call it Handler
where she's introducing him to really
wealthy and powerful people to then go
blackmail she's also probably
introducing him to the contacts in these
intelligence agencies potentially the
Mossad and maybe others because her
father was a Mossad agent and Seymour
Hersh wrote a book about that Robert
Maxwell was a media mogul but had you
know died a very shady way worked for
the Mossad so this isn't a new angle
here but the media just got to it and
they're they're really looking to get
rid of her we're gonna find out in a few
years by the way because every news
story is so insane you can't trust
anybody now we're gonna find out in a
few years he obviously was a good guy he
was like a mentally deficient guy who
had no idea what was going on on his
island he was just one of the
groundskeepers he thought they were
literally running like a [ __ ] summer
camp on the island he had no idea that's
what's gonna come out yeah Jeffery was
just you know he was like a simpleton
who had no idea just used to walk around
in a big armored sweatshirt
he's the fall guy we're gonna find that
out find that out in a few years when
the epstein truth is come out I had a
Sandusky truther sent me a book once
that's what I knew my career was heading
in the right direction when a guy who
was like you gotta take another look
into the Sandusky thing the other thing
folks is there are no conspiracies
anymore it's all out in front of you
so if you've got some far-off real like
wild take on this you're wrong
cuz this is all in the front it's here
we know what it is we don't know who was
compromised we don't know who bow in
many cases we do even know who was on
the island so the idea of like you know
know third swords a whole other thing
you haven't even thought of it's not
it's not we got it they're no more
conspiracies 2020 is gonna be the year
the conspiracy died it's just the news
now it's the news there's never been a
time in America when less has been
hidden from your fat face it's all in
front of you you can choose to believe
it or not to believe it but it's it's
everything you thought doesn't mean that
there aren't things they're not gonna
try to keep from you I'm sure there are
but their ability to do that seems to be
less and less they just don't have the
ability to keep things under wrap the
way they used to certain things sure
like nobody believes that Steven paddock
thing nobody knows why they don't
believe it we just don't believe it like
it could even gotten the shots off gonna
get maybe but it's just a creepy
shadiest thing ever this guy very you
know like no social media presence flips
out no motive does this whole thing his
girlfriend deletes her Facebook account
an hour later claimed she had no you
know the internet name of the shooter
hadn't been released yet but she deletes
her facebook she flies to the
Philippines the guy's ordering for two
people in his room but he stayed there
alone blah blah blah
nobody believes it everybody just shrugs
and goes yeah that's where I don't know
I don't know what do we having for
dinner you know it's crazy you just
expected to believe it you're expected
to believe it you just go okay sure yeah
and maybe it happened but there's no
real effort to get to the bottom of
anything
same thing that those two kids who blew
up the Boston Marathon and FBI think we
don't know who they are rush
intelligence is like yeah you do and
then the FBI was like yeah you're right
we do yeah you're right we do it's like
what that was what the [ __ ] is that what
do you mean you don't know good they do
FBI snot like a Chili's right where you
like I don't know if we have to sell
those to that growth tonight did we ran
out oh no no we got them like there's
there's there's more behind the scenes
working there right you you guys before
you come out and make public statements
you'd do a little [ __ ] research into
whether you knew who these people were
yeah we knew them we're sorry and then
they go interview one of the friends in
a hotel room and end up killing him
the feds end up killing the friend and
you have to just go yeah that makes
sense
that makes sense that they would denied
knowing you the two guys were and then
admit that they knew him and then go and
kill their friend in the hotel and then
nobody's heard anything about the trial
because his special administrative
measures put on all the lawyers and none
of the lawyers have ever been
interviewed and blabbity blabbity blew
yet all works all make sense what's the
dinner we need yeah I mean that's so
there are still things we're but we know
again like it's like it's not
conspiracies it's just you like yeah
they'd say doesn't wash doesn't make any
sense you do what you want to do you
want to talk about Trump but Jesus in
the time machine and queueing on
whatever makes you feel better
I just go [ __ ] me I don't know I don't
know you guys do what you want to do
talk about the black cube and Saturn and
Satan and I go yeah all right maybe
maybe so you ain't doing nothing what
YouTube comments and you it's just that
he's not really doing much
you know if you you know make some
produce some put something out there
with evidence with sources and still
won't matter but at least do that but
your unsourced YouTube comments probably
not really the idea that you've figured
it out is not believable to me cuz I
think you might have brain damage that's
all I'm gonna get away with every now
I'm just gonna go I have brain damage
mr. Dylan you are wildly inappropriate
I'm sorry I have brain damage my brain
does not work well unless you're not mad
at me in which case it's fine if you're
angry at me for any reason it means my
brain is malfunctioning because it's
damaged you know it's a lot of fun folks
you just gotta enjoy it you just gotta
enjoy it and at the end of the day you
gotta laugh at it otherwise you'll go
crazy if you don't laugh
protect your friends and family try to
get the justice you can get love to see
these people behind bars love to see it
happen love to see just lame acts while
behind bars for what she's done I'm not
one of these people who doesn't want to
see justice or thinks it's completely
impossible I just think it's unlikely
it's difference it's not black billing
to say it's unlikely could happen almost
happen with Jeffery they got in there
though
and you know they're by the way
podcasting three years from now and now
we know that Jeffery was just a mentally
deficient groundskeeper that all of the
people who were really running the cult
they were just using this guy's name he
had no idea what's going on
[Music]
I mean can you imagine that in four
years we're just rehabilitating the
image of abstain we have besmirched the
name of a good man I said Kathy Griffin
got married on Twitter man she loves a
spotlight huh she really loves a
spotlight something interesting about
her she just you know she really wants
not a minute of private time she doesn't
want any of that she has no interest in
that Lily Tomlin officiated her wedding
on Twitter and you're like I listen I
post a lot of [ __ ] I'm you know a public
person to a degree I'm not nearly I
don't have nearly the profile that she
does she's much more successful but do
you ever wonder about just taking a
minute to yourself I mean I don't know
God lover I guess maybe we could get
back at Andy Cohen and Anderson Cooper
because they were doing something on New
Year's Eve and she's like [ __ ] those
guys by the way I thought what she did
was stupid with the Trump head but I
thought that those people that abandon
her sucked and [ __ ] them but their
corporate I mean you know Cooper's a
Vanderbilt who works for CNN Andy Cohen
has a network where they you know have
shows where you know people kill
themselves during the show you know the
Real Housewives people OFF themselves in
front of their kids and they set it to
music that's what he does that's his
cultural contribution to the world he's
to film people's breakdowns to film
people's drug addiction and breakdowns
and then put give you a glass of wine
and go hey there's a load of gun in the
parlor cameras on action you know
that's what he did he's responsible for
Trump is anyone by the way Andy Cohen
Bravo are as responsible for the rise of
Donald Trump as anybody because they
legitimize that stuff that trainwreck
you know that obsession with watching a
car crash in slow-mo with watching
orchestrated and doctored reality that
you knew was fake but was just
entertaining so you didn't care you know
you want to start blaming people you do
a lot worse than blaming Andy Cohen for
that by the way and those shows which I
admit I've watched some of them are
enjoyable but when I look back and I can
zoom out I go yes you know probably a
negative thing for the kids on that show
that we're watching their dad killed
himself that's probably not good you
know I mean you want to see you want to
start pointing a finger you want to
start you know you could do a lot worse
than [ __ ] Andy Cohen but maybe that
was what she was trying to do maybe she
was trying to say [ __ ] you guys I'm
gonna get married and take some eyeballs
away from Anderson Cooper and Andy Cohen
who people got mad at because they said
[ __ ] on CNN at midnight or whatever it's
like again if you're not mad at Trump
you can't get mad at that otherwise you
like okay well we just don't think gay
people should be able to say anything
vulgar if that's your then that's fine
but the President of the United States
is making fun of Megyn Kelly's period in
a debate so if that doesn't bother you
and you and you don't think that's bad
for your kids then I don't know why your
kids are awake at midnight watching CNN
either on New Year's Eve what kind of
parent are you that your kids are
watching CNN at midnight with two drunk
gay guys think the audience for that is
number one the or is no one I don't know
why anyone's watching anything on your
New Year's
programmers should be turned on the
minute before the ball and turned off
the minute after New Year's it should be
a three minute viewing experience no boy
no I like to do banter I want to hear
the bed with her then you get a friend
and you speak to them do you see how
that work no I like banter me and my
girl like to watch New Year's because
there's gonna be a performance by post
Malone who's great I'm not shooting a
post blonde but you know you don't need
this all these people man they look it's
the generous E of CNN it's like did the
president of United States is making fun
of some chicks period on prime time
during a debate which kids are some of
them are told to watch for school and
he's you know or maybe didn't say it in
the debate but he said it it was in the
news cycle he said it right afterwards
and that's like one of the more tame
things he said every day fire something
off so it was like you either just
letting it fly or not I agree with you
yeah they probably shouldn't have said
[ __ ] he shouldn't say anything he says
and everybody should go back to not
speaking every thought that enters their
head but we with it's not what we have
going here folks we got a real
free-for-all happening we got a goddamn
free-for-all going on so you gotta be
somewhat consistent don't let your kids
watch anything I don't know what to tell
you
that's what most people do with kids
they sit him in front of a TV and check
in with them twice and then they're 18
it's not the move I see with these
parents you they give the kid an iPad
and say good luck good luck you know
mom's depressed I can't do anything with
you today go play on the iPad
I'm gonna go sulk on the couch I'm not
denigrating people with serious mental
illness but there's millions and
millions of people in these countries
that are literally pretending to be
mentally ill and it's it's bothering me
and I've always had this idea about
therapy here's the thing with therapy
folks and this is another hot take that
will not be appreciated by everybody
here we go
75% a therapy are you ready for this and
when you see each here by Stephen
paddocks leaving bye-bye
alright I'll see ya he's so funny we
have we tried to do once a month lunch
we're both in town 75% of all therapy is
useless garbage you're not meant to get
to the bottom of it all life is too
short
daddy didn't love you what it may be if
he [ __ ] you okay
you need some but the idea that okay you
didn't have the perfect parents or the
perfect upbringing or with a you I'm
telling you right now plumbing the
depths of it for the rest of your life
is going to do nothing for you ignore it
compartmentalize it put it in a lock box
as Al Gore would say he was running for
president cuz who put Social Security
lockbox compartmentalize learn how to do
that it's very helpful you don't have to
and sometimes you should be sad life's
about that maybe you're at a bar you're
alone you have a couple of drinks it's
the right time to be sad then open the
compartment and take out all the [ __ ]
you have to be sad about and be sad you
hear a song come on in the car oh it's
time to be sad well up with tears
it's sad time and then you get where
you're going and you go okay we're
putting it back in the compartment zip
it up and then we're gonna go be
productive and do something else I don't
think you have to
figure it all out because you're not
going to you're gonna have to live and
let live
therapy by the way let's be honest right
now how many people are useless and then
halfway through the conversation you go
what do you what do you school for what
are you doing to go I'm a therapist
let's be honest my friend Michelle wants
to be a love therapist she spent three
failed marriages she was to be a couples
therapist these are the people getting
into this I mean think back on the last
person told you they were therapists I
guarantee you it was somebody where you
went
that person has nothing meaningful to
add to anything I'm telling you the
truth
and there are a few that are that are
good and there are people that genuinely
need therapy need help but there's
there's a lot of people this is a little
bit of a hustle out there it's a little
bit of a con job going on for people
with college degrees you don't really
know what to do so they're gonna sit on
their ass and listen to you talk about
the fact that your dad was not as
supportive as you should have been hey
boo-hoo-hoo
grow up stop thinking about it if it
bothers you figure out a way to stop
thinking about it you have power over
your own mind here's why there appease
become necessary because we're telling
everyone they have to get to the bottom
of everything and they have to be okay
with everything and everybody which is
insane that's why therapists that's why
they make millions and millions of
dollars because we've told everybody
that before you leave planet Earth you
gotta be okay with everyone that's ever
wronged you and you got to make peace
with everything which isn't true
you just have to forget about it so that
it doesn't [ __ ] impact your day to
day life you don't have to make peace
with it in fact in some cases people
that never make peace whether they're
very successful because there's a part
of it that still drives them to do
things so enough with the sarahfey [ __ ]
literally
enough with this self-care stuff I've
done this before on the show but this
idea of self-care we're a deeply selfish
country of demons the idea that any of
our problems are because people in
America are not thinking enough about
themselves is hilarious that is the
funniest thing I've ever heard that if
you were to diagnose this country's
issues you would say there's just too
many do-gooders that's America's problem
what do you think America's problem is
well from what I've observed there's
just too many people looking out for
each other really yeah that's what I
think their biggest issue is and these
people are tired all day from feeding
and housing the homeless and they just
can't really they can't do anything for
themselves so they need self-care which
means nothing at all what does it mean
masturbating with a candle it means
nothing taking a bath
everything you do all day is self-care
that $3,800 front Pacino that you drink
in your car is self-care you're pumping
yourself full of drugs self-care that
vacation you took self-care the kids you
half raised because you want to watch
Bravo self-care the reality TV he
watches self-care everything you do is
self-care there is no other care by the
way nobody's pioneer that nobody's
thought about that yet so therapy goes
into self-care where they're like well I
just gotta I just gotta talk to someone
about everything apart and you really
said most of the people in therapy by
the way let's be honest have lived nice
lives let's be really honest most of the
people in therapy and very nice envy
Abul our lives that any of us would have
wanted to live a lot of people that
should be in therapy because they were
genuinely [ __ ] over don't have the
money to do it it's not an option for
them and I'm not saying that all therapy
is bad I'm saying
a lot of it is garbage I said 75% I
still think I stick with that 75% I
think is garbage self care I just need
some time to talk about myself for all
the things that bother me
well you don't have to talk about them
because you don't have to think about
them you can actually just put them
somewhere where you can't get to them
and then bring them out whenever you
need them and then put them back in
that's all that can be done we've over
we've it's we've overdone it with the
chit with the Chatty Cathy and I think
we know we have you know I just me I II
want you and then I think I just think
that my you know like the commitment
issues that like he has but then I also
shut up and do something you privileged
I mean the idea what these people talk
about in therapy I don't know I just
think maybe it's a fear that I ever that
maybe that he has but I did just a fear
that like is it's just like it was so
good it was bad like do you know what I
mean like you know it do you know what
it is get a job
do something stop burdening yourself
forget other people they're making money
by the way
stop burdening yourself with these
thoughts that you you you people are
just masochist by the very nature they
want to drown themselves in negativity
and negative thoughts this is our nature
as human beings to do I don't know if it
goes back to the really you know eating
the Apple and we're born of sin and
whatever I don't know where it goes but
I don't care
it may be deeper than that but what it
is is it's just indulgent and when you
indulge certain thoughts and certain
patterns of behaviors stop indulging the
shed cut it off you know I know that if
I wanted to lose weight I can lose
weight
I should I should but it's not a
therapist
is it gonna I know exactly why I eat so
me paying $100 to a therapist to tell
her why I eat or him does it make any
sense it just it makes sense for the
therapist because they need to make
money you know there was a whole thing
about 12-step programs in the patriarchy
of a a this this this article that was
written which you know was like a a a
patriarchy so instead of people so bring
up they can they can shout Yas Queen as
they relapse and die great article my
criticism of therapy is not meant to
broad-brush everything I think there is
validity to certain 12-step programs I
think there is validity some forms of
therapy the people really need but let's
not pretend that we haven't blown the
whole thing out of proportion
treating mental health like some fad and
you just you know a lot of the reasons
you hate yourself a salad they're valid
reason your your right my friend once
said to his father because I think I'm
depressed he goes you're 40 years old
you have no career no family no money
and a woman you should be depressed now
if that was therapy I'd say go to it
every day if that was therapy but that's
not there if you'd be like well why do
you think do you think that do you think
it would be constructive for you to put
no his father was like you're a loser
and that's why you're sad
there's a reason you're anxious there's
a reason you said there's a reason
you're depressed most people want to go
to therapy because they want to keep
doing the thing that makes them anxious
and depressed and somehow mitigate that
think I'm in a horrible relationship but
I'd like to stay in it and go to therapy
to mitigate its effects on me I'm in the
wrong job but I'd like to just stay at
it and go to therapy so that they could
teach me some coping mechanisms so I
continue to so I could continue to live
the absolutely wrong way and mitigate
the effects of doing so that's what most
therapy is
I'm miserable and I made all the wrong
decisions I'd like to I'd like to
continue to making bad decisions but I
want to be happy now are we by
you-know-who no right
you-know-who okay it kind of looks like
we were though okay I'm just I don't
want to get a role I know people gonna
go not to me for the therapy ramp but
you know what sometimes you just got to
do it folks
sometimes we just got to do it I love
all these people congratulating each
other for getting into therapy well
congrats Congrats you're in therapy stop
will you stop a real therapy should be
somebody has to deal my mother well my
mother says totally batshit off the wall
crazy stuff and the real therapist is
like um do you have any proof that your
sisters in the FBI like that's what a
real therapy should have to do not
listen to you to talk about your gash
for a nap for an hour if you really need
it you need it but there's another side
type of therapy that nobody puts any
credence in and it's called forgetting
forgetting what happened
accept people as they are don't arrange
the world in the way that you needed to
be arranged enough with it don't think
about it you know how long have we done
here we're at 77 if I have a I will say
this folks you know podcasting is so
funny we wonder when like the podcast
bubble is gonna burst I love like the
girls got any podcast was very
successful those girls are very funny
they went on I was watching an interview
that they did with like I don't have
some Windy City Chicago and like you
these newscasters are just starting to
get like podcaster just trying to get on
the radar now if newscasters like local
news people so that when these girls go
in and they pack a whole theater out
they have to go and like you know they
do this local news stuff and then the
people at the local news desk are like
what is this podcasting what are you
doing and
like those girls make more money if you
know how much money they made you blow
your brains out
right there at KABC Chicago you'd blow
your brains right out if those girls
told you how much money what is this
podcasting what's going on a lot of
people of these podcasts now yeah you
think should just write a number on the
pad and say this is what I made last
month and then you see newscasters you
see their faces go go blank for a minute
and then they would just like swallow
hard there was like gulp and then they'd
have to get on because newscasters are
are basically selling their [ __ ] in the
street right now local newscasters I
mean those people are like they'd love
to get traffic to Epstein's Island they
think those girls had a good I just love
the idea of like yes for dismissively
about pod can't what's this what's this
podcast everybody doing what are you
girls make they just turn around they
just write a number on a pad to go
here's what we met here's really made
last year and then the local news
anchors just her like oh gosh and they
just take out a gun and they blow their
brains out I think that would be Hillier
I'm trying to write a sitcom about a kid
who's building a tick-tock Empire and
he's the only one in his family who
works and he has to me he makes them do
more and more demeaning [ __ ] all the
time but this is the only way that he
you know the family can make any money
so the kid like four system like the
grandmother has cancer but he forced to
sort of like do tick tocks and like
smoke weed and everything and like it's
just part of it's part of trying to come
up with something I think that might be
fun just like social media being the
only way out you have this Rust Belt
family that's taking orders from this 15
year old tic-tock er because he's their
only shot kind of like that show the
other one a Comedy Central that failed
spectacularly remember that
funny and then they didn't know how to
market it now knowing now it's gone
about the young YouTube kid and he had
the the disciplines that were failed
failures in the business or whatever
we're near do Wells and he was the only
one that could make it work that's good
they're in a good place over there
they're in a good they're in a good
place
cable TV the future
basic cable the future I'm trying to
think if I had one channel right now if
I could own one channel what would I
want to own
maybe Lifetime television for women cuz
that you can just ratchet up and get
crazier and there's gonna be like an
audience for it but like a comedy
channel they're just gonna go to the
Internet but lifetimes got a real
specific audience of like women that
wish they were beaten that's like the
women that watch lifetime women that
wish anyone cared enough about them to
hit them they would love the passion of
a hand smacking their face that's who
watch his lifetime so I think with that
group of people watch and you could do a
lot the future is real bright
if that's your crew cuz they'll take the
ride with you Tim you like comedy comm
we have a lot of we have a lot of great
a lot of great opportunities for you
we're launching our jewelry line very
soon we can go door to door and kind of
get people involved in low-cost highly
made jewelry we have a 12-point plan
we'll be sending out to you about how to
sell that how to enrich yourselves your
friends and your family it's all about
multiple revenue streams right now you
don't need a brick-and-mortar office but
you need guidance from a proven and
tested sales team led by someone with a
vision and that will be me we'll be
talking about that people people that
don't know you were threatened by you
we'll call it a Ponzi scheme it'll call
multi-level marketing
they'll say that we're taking advantage
of you they will say that it's not a
real job but it is clearly fraud it is
those people are scared of you and they
don't want to see you do well so we're
very excited to kind of introduce our
new jewelry line of watches earrings and
it's gonna go like this like you knock
on someone's door you go hi hello got a
dress nice look like a jeweler looked
like somebody would buy jewelry from
because you're selling jewelry
door-to-door low-cost highly made
jewelry that can resell they can times
are tough they can boil it down it can
melt it down but it's gonna really
enrich their lives so what you do is you
knock on the door and you say hi let's
just say your name is Carol hi my name
is Carol and I'm with Dylan Jules would
you would you would you have any a few
min hey they're gonna sign your face she
the first lines got to be very important
you could do you have any time today
discuss low cost well-made jewelry we
want to get you in a plan on a plan in a
plan hey we want to get you look look
him in the eye
hi my name is Carol I'm from Dillon
jewels do you know time today and that's
cuz you do high voice good do a lot of
time today to talk about low-cost highly
made now hold on
low cost well-made jewelry from from
podcaster Tim Miller podcasters him
Dylan has had a passion for jewelry
entire life he goes and buys e stones at
the diamond district
he cuts him himself he supervises it
while other people do the stone cutting
and we get him out to you for low cost
low money and what you can do is then
you can start selling these to your
friends and family we want the jewels to
go to you and we want you to bring the
jewels to your friends
and we were gonna call it run the jewels
and then we got sued but that's where
what we want so you gonna have to learn
how to sell cuz it's not a that is a
little bit of a rough sell knocking on
someone's door trying to talk to them
about jewelry what do you do for a
living if you ever thought about selling
jewelry if you ever thought about
creating opportunities for yourself and
your family
well how about creating opportunities
for yourself and your family with low
cost low cost well-made jewelry from
podcaster Tim Dillon do you feel do you
feel do you feel like sometimes your job
you're boxed in or you hit a ceiling do
you not want to feel like that is
twenty-twenty gonna be your year or not
maybe that's the entrance point you look
at them and go hey let me ask you a
question you're on the doorstep
it's 2020 gonna be your year and if they
say no go why not and if they say yeah
say why and here's the thing you have
the same here's what your you over you
have an ace-in-the-hole
because the answer to this question is
the same no matter what they say and
it's Jules there to sell jewelry you
have to tell them that no matter what
happens the guy's not my ears well
you're not selling jewelry
it is my year and you go nope you gotta
sell jewels by Dylan and you say to them
have you ever heard of multi-level
marketing it's very different than a
Ponzi scheme
say that right away say that right away
because they need to know that what
you're doing is different than what
other people do so I'm not here selling
you that's another one you do go I'm not
here to sell anything you what I'm here
to do is get you involved in an
opportunity and the opportunities
actually just create opportunities for
your family and friend with a line of
jewelry that you will sell door-to-door
for Dillon jewels that's all so we're
very excited about that that's rolling
out and then if you're interested in
that we have a course that we're gonna
give at the Scottsdale Marriott and the
$7,800 but it includes four days
breakfast and non-stop seminars where we
introduce you to the jewelry and about
selling the jewelry and we talk about a
lot of things that are gonna be
essential if you want to create
opportunities because that's the
business we're in its the creating of
opportunities so $7,800 you could you
could you could you could finance a
charge take out a credit card put that
eight G's on the card put it on the card
do you think Warren Buffett would be
where he is today if he didn't do
everything he could to go to a seminar
in the Scottsdale Marriott about selling
jewelry by the way as I do this as a
joke I some of you were so stupid that
I'm doing myself a disservice by not
ripping you off more you know what I
mean like what Gary Vee and all them
have realized about the planet is that
many of you don't deserve to not be
robbed
that's what Gary's really he's like no
rob there they they're there to be
robbed there's that dumb just take it
from them Tim to the comedy calm for all
our dates that are coming up please come
to the shows they're very fun Tim Jay
Dylan di llo and on Instagram Twitter
follow tell your friends about the show
we got a lot of live events coming up
we're all over the place please
this is gonna be our year not because of
comedy we don't really care about that
but because of the jewel business that
we are starting and I want you to take
it seriously she's not a joke
there is a mailing list on my website
sign up for the millions it says we're
gonna alert you about live shows and
stuff here's what's really gonna happen
we're gonna give you the ammunition well
out was we decided that wasn't a good
word so all the school training we're
gonna give you the resources to create
opportunities for your friends and your
family by selling high quality
low costs jewelry door-to-door or in
your office until they threaten to fire
you because that will happen because
they're playing haters they are player
haters wherever you work but before they
do you set up a little kiosk at
Applebee's right on the bar now the
manager is gonna come up to you at
Applebee's and he's gonna go why do you
all these turquoise necklaces on the bar
and you go if you heard uh Dylan jewels
by Dylan by podcaster Jim Dylan I said
he's gonna go you can't do that here you
can't do that here you cannot sling
turquoise jewelry from the sample bees
and you say it is low-cost high-quality
jewelry straight his face high cost look
see I [ __ ] it up again eyes hot cost
low quality that's it that is the
hardest thing about this it's not the
hardest thing about it is to not say
high cost low quality because then then
even though you can laugh it off people
are still believe that that's the case
so you have to do is say low cost high
call you gotta practice in the mirror
low cost high quality low cost high
quiet and if you can't do your wife get
in your face while you're doing this
uhyou let's ain't hit him but mushroom
shove him get him out of there
low cost high quality low cost high
quality and that's what he says you
cannot sell jewelry like this at this
island burgers and shakes that you work
at you go hey it's low cost high quality
I'm just creating opportunities for
people so that's who
to do here we'll try to get out of this
trying to get a merge game but I don't I
don't want to just do standard merge I
want you guys to follow me into a pit
and I think the baths the best way to do
the best way to do that
what is everybody like jewelry but
what's the problem with jewelry
oftentimes what is it high costs low
quality we've solved that cuz this is
high quality low cost and what's the
other problem truly you got to go get it
or wait for someone to love you enough
to give it to you and not gonna happen
ladies watching lifetime you get your
own jewels ephah so what you have to do
is in your own home you can have little
parties like Tupperware parties where
you get a bunch of your single women
friends together no the reason that
nobody [ __ ] us and loves us is because
we don't have high quality low cost
jewelry on ourselves at all times and if
we did we would look better and we'd be
able to you know enrich yourself or your
friends like for example let's say I'm
having lunch Ben doesn't have a mic out
for himself but it doesn't matter you
can imagine Ben mm you're having lunch I
haven't seen Ben in a while because this
is the thing you your friends are your
your business base now you're the people
you're gonna sell to your family that
people gonna sell to so I haven't seen
Ben in a while I request him on Facebook
we haven't seen each other in 10 years
now we're gonna go out to a lunch I'm
going to sell him the jewelry listen to
this we are at now at lunch where where
would we be having lunch maybe we're at
Panera Bread okay hey Ben good to catch
up with you hey I haven't seen you in so
long man it's been a very long time what
have you been up to not much just
podcasting out here you know just living
in LA you go back to New York what are
you doing what are you up to
okay none of that would happen okay so
Ben
venez already saying things it won't
happen that's not what's gonna happen
here's what will happen I'm gonna be the
person sitting there Ben's gonna be me
because he can't even handle doing the
part of the buyer that's not how people
talk I'm gonna let your New York no one
talks like that
it's [ __ ] elitist cut now you're now
Mary I'm the BA I'm the buyer okay hey
hey hey Ben you want to buy some jewelry
no you don't start like that you have to
just say hello first establish rapport
build rapport hey man it's good to see
you haven't seen you in so long it's
very good to see you I'm looking into
creating opportunities for myself and my
family sometimes as if I don't have
anywhere to turn do you think is there
any potential Avenue you see to me
making any profit in 2020 even involve
like direct to market sales I have a
great persona and personality and a
large network of family and friends it's
ever-expanding I would like to take
advantage of that Network and sell them
things maybe jewelry do you have any
ideas have you heard of podcaster Tim
Dylan's jewelry we sell it at a low cost
high quality whoa the jewelry is
high-quality but it is low cost so I
don't have to spend a lot of money to
give my friends and family something
that is very beautiful is that correct
that's good
is there a seminar where I could learn
about this jewelry I will spend up to
$10,000 on this seminar how much is a
seminar it's 5,000 tall I am so happy I
may take it now twice is it in Arizona
at the Scottsdale Marriott that's right
very good well this is a good launch I
don't want to waste any more time eating
at Panera
because I want to start booking tickets
to go to the Marriott so I can sell
jewelry for podcast
Jim Dylan because he's sick of comedy
and everyone in it so he wants to just
rip people off now because he's the
idiot that is it he's the one person
who's not hitting people in the head
with a shovel and they're mad about they
go why aren't you hitting me in the head
with a shovel my head is here and
there's a shovel get to work
goodbye folks